(upbeat music)
(audience cheers)
(Wendy giggles)
- I'm gonna lead with this
'cause you look so fabulous.
You said, did your brother, was
your brother a part of this?
- My brother made this.
Isn't this wonderful?
(audience cheers)
(Wendy cheers)
- Yes.
- That's like
something I would wear on tour
with the see-through aspect,
the whole catsuit
underneath, it's so cute.
I love it so much, it's so hot.
Anyway-
- Thank you!
- I had to say that.
- Oh!
- Have you met Nick before?
- No, and I'm fanning out.
I'm trying to contain myself,
(audience laughs)
but no, I love you.
I love you, I've loved you for
years, you and your brothers.
(Kelly giggles)
Pleasure.
- Nice to meet you.
- Pleasure.
- Alright,
so you got to play Issa
Rae's mom on Insecure, right?
- Yes, yes.
- Yeah.
So that was,
you have a connection with her
that I think is really remarkable
'cause I wanna get to what you do-
- Wow.
- in a minute as well.
So how do you know her?
Tell everybody.
- So 26 years ago, I co-founded
Amazing Grace Conservatory.
It's my passion project.
It's a performing arts school.
In south LA.
- It's an incredible project.
Yeah.
- Thank you.
And we've had some incredible
alumni to come out,
and Issa Rae was one of them.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Ashton Sanders.
He's currently in "I
Wanna Dance With Somebody"
playing Bobby Brown,
and she was one of my students.
- Yeah.
- And then to come full circle
and to see what she has done-
- Yeah.
- in this industry is just, it's amazing.
And I played her mom,
so it was such a incredible
full-circle moment
'cause I was still in awe of, you know,
everything that she's been
doing and what she is, you know,
and she's created a pipeline
for so many young people,
especially alumni out of
Amazing Grace Conservatory.
- Because she was taught to do that,
because that's what you started.
That domino effect is incredible.
- It is.
(audience cheers)
- And I think it's such a
testament to what you're doing
that people are coming out of it
and having success and feeling
confident and landing jobs.
Like that's an incredible thing.
- Thank you.
- I learned about that and I
was like, I didn't know that.
That's super cool.
- Wow.
- Yeah.
- And I, you know,
we started it as two struggling artists.
You know, my best friend-
- As we all do.
- Hello, hello!
- Yeah.
Who hasn't been a waitress?
(Wendy and Kelly laugh)
- Well I haven't, thank God,
they don't want me waitin'.
(Kelly screams)
Girl!
(audience laughs)
They don't want me waiting tables.
(Wendy laughs)
- I feel like
we were all waiters or
waitresses at some point.
- I tried, I'm a little clumsy.
- So your show is called "The Game,"
and it's been on since 2006.
So, but this is the second
season of the revival, right?
- It's the second, yeah.
I wanna call it a "re-imagining."
- Okay, re-imagining.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, I like that too.
- Yes.
Not a reboot, but it's a
re-imagining of "The Game."
Yeah.
- So why
do you like to call it that instead?
- Because, you know, it's
familiar, but it's fresh.
- Yeah.
- So we kept
a lot of the same elements,
but it's, we just upped
the antes of it, you know?
- Yeah.
- It was originally set
in San Diego,
so all the characters
were there in San Diego,
and now we've moved the show to Vegas.
- Yeah.
- So it's hot, it's spicy.
- Very different town.
- Woo, very different!
- Yeah.
- You know what happens
in Vegas stays in Vegas.
- Yeah.
- Unless it's on "The Game."
- Sometimes it follows you home.
- Exactly, exactly.
So we've added some
incredible talent to the cast.
- Yeah.
- And it's shown through the lens
of the daughter of one of
the original cast members.
- Yeah, I love that.
- Yeah, so it gives a
whole new perspective
of the show from football.
It starts about football,
but it really holds up
a mirror to America.
- Yeah.
- And everything
that we're going through,
and football just happens
to be the platform.
- I think it's important
too that art does that,
is that you do talk about
what's going on in the world.
I think that's where art is helpful.
- Right.
- Because you make
something thought-provoking
that ends up, the progress
happens from that.
Hopefully that's the goal.
- Exactly.
- Yeah.
- Oh, we're in Vegas,
so maybe we can come to your residency.
- You should.
- Yes.
(audience cheers)
- I'm telling you, that's a good time.
- Yes, I know that would be a good time.
- A lot of fun.
- It's a good time.
And I will tell you,
the thing I love about your audience too
'cause I was like, I didn't
really know like what to expect,
and I was like, "alright, I'm 40,
I'm showing up, I'm doing it."
(Wendy laughs)
And I'm like, I just love
the musics, whatever.
You have such a a broad fan base.
Every-
- Yes.
- every culture, every age, every,
it was really cool.
I love the show.
I think that's cool
that music can do that.
Bring people together-
- Absolutely.
- that maybe wouldn't be
the best in the same room,
or art does that in general.
- You should definitely come to the show.